hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to spooky's house of
Jairus
I forgot to hit my recording button
again you're in luck cuz nothing nothing
new happened yet until just then hi in
order to survive keep writing notes
what's trihard is ik oh the tall man
character okay that's referring to the
Slender Man I don't know what's done
that long huh this seems a little bit
different before right before right up
until the point where I actually started
why should go down that that's probably
call me I'm curious
no I'm not that curious oh I'm curious
what's down here and why can I suddenly
sprint now oh crap it's gonna be into
the death of me all this the death of me
I shouldn't gone down here oh I
shouldn't have done this I shouldn't
have done this oh I shouldn't have done
this
oh this is death of me oh oh it's the
death of me oh it's the death of me oh I
shouldn't have done this oh crap hold my
bath hole okay okay okay all right never
mind it might be something you never
know never know or it could kill me
again and that was the one time that I
could have gotten away let's buy the
point of no return I done goofed
I done goofed
getting closer getting a little closer a
little bit maybe a little bit poopy
this is a mistake oh this is horrible
okay I think it's getting all god damn
it no no I refuse I refuse
ah crap I'm dead ah crap crap Ola Oh God
Jesus oh oh it was doing the thing it
was doing the thing uh-huh
I've been killed by that before but only
a long time ago I'm not gonna be filming
it again
that was so stupid it's a big waste of
my time
also what happened to my unlimited ham
and a gift what happened to that I guess
spooky just different feel like it oh
crap oh crap what does this mean
I forget what this means what does this
mean whoa whoa is this mean what is this
mean
with the Fed the Fed
hit the sink at the funk what the funk
soul brother this is the only thing that
you guys miss because of my bad pressing
of buttons was that room there with the
red outline I haven't seen that yet
that's your funk is going on Nike Nike I
don't like this a little bit oh no oh
god no oh God
said senpai [ __ ] was that [ __ ]
go Jesus go yeah [ __ ] yeah go go
Oh God why why why why I didn't know
it's not like you're gonna go any faster
oh crap oh crap I'm gonna die come on
Jack oh my doc I'm here somebody are
boys
okay okay Oh God
oh my dad oh oh
well that's wrong to me what the
[ __ ] after that what whole games a
bunch of [ __ ] I don't know if it's
still there might still be there can't
be too cautious
Oh still there I still hear you
absolutely no no no no no no there's a
little Yantra no come on a pumping you
know what something tells me I agree
with you now hiring cow feeders I know I
want a cow fader
there's causing a majestic beef grinding
machine that tells me no one wants to be
granted my beef on that okay all right
let's keep going bloody down button
let's go come on
oh that's for that
lovely mcdonald's that no one would ever
ever ever want to eat oh boy oh boy
let's do this I don't know why I let
that get to me like I do shouldn't well
there's a little different now oh boy
what does a little weird oh this chains
on the walls
do I need to us down the axe for some
reason probably hopefully not though
crap damn it
damnit
there we go okay gotta go okay moving
forward sit on I there's gonna be chains
in the walls pull all the weird noises
that are happening in here I don't much
care for it
bunch of baloney jerky in a bunch of
baloney whoa what is this
wow what a mansion inside another
mansion maybe I've made it all the way
to the end of the house maybe this is
like a resting place or another entrance
perhaps whatever the case I think this
is a good spot to rest is it that's how
people die well whoa that's a little
bizarre why is that the way that that is
wait okay yeah this is all raw all rip
whoa what the Dukes is all room 810 okay
yeah and he did oh oh now that's all
wonky
why is that wonky okay the mansion is
strange
I think the bricks and wood are actually
just painted on everything still feels
kind of fake also I keep hearing
movement and voices below me maybe other
survivors are hiding down there you seem
to be awfully hopeful for someone that's
probably going to die and awfully
hopeful for someone that's made it this
far along how have you survived this
long if this is how naive you are
okay so it's like a boxed area a little
contained some of the walls are a little
warbly that one's broken broken gray
bird that's what's not okay whew
the wine cellar
I can hear him coming down the hallway I
need to hide but I don't know where I
knows it's not an exit or resting
bayside just another specimen room
inside the door now hold up hold up
okay all right then
Oh Bogut okay it's okay it's okay it's
all right he's just a little twitchy
he's got a scythe he's gonna sighs I got
an axe
let's see you wins in a fight probably
he'll keep
okay hooray thank you note on the ground
okay is it okay safe safe safe safety
safe say if save question mark save of
course it was another specimen room of
course it was what else could have
possibly been okay
hi okay that's over I can go upstairs
try to explore those places oh I can't
go upstairs oh I can yes okay locked
locked okay there was no point in doing
any of that I can't just move forward
now why did I even bother with all that
bull why me Bob
goddamnit hmm bedroom oh okay oh that's
how it's gonna be
wait then I want to try the Albany
arrows I want to try the Albany rose
there are good oh goody
Oh No
I find another hidey-hole is it time yet
wait hang on maybe it's not time I gotta
find something oh crap
nope no probably time let's go in here
crap another one of these games
well that's the sound of a murderous
murderer I'll just stick here with my
curiously strong mints that they ate a
whole mouth I had a whole tinnitus I did
I did do he I didn't be outdoors
challenge hello hi friend
oh you're Twiggy which was I took hold
ten of out wives I tried to eat him all
in under him in under a minute yeah you
never think closet what was it okay oh
cool
he dropped that thing that was so nice
of him to do that
great okay was this a key - oh god of
course oh god no no these things I
somehow managed to get away but I don't
know for how long I hear him even when I
know he's not there it's like he's isn't
even real but instead my own fear
manifesting themselves to talk okay good
well what was my party coming in here
crap well I can't even go in there
alright then I'll just take a nap good
for me crap okay so was that like a key
to the whole house maybe maybe I can go
anywhere now maybe okay oh I can oh cool
oh cool cool cool cool
wait is this cool let's go might not be
cool I don't know if it's cool okay
sorry this led to broken doors those are
broken okay so there was another locked
door the other side that was broken but
I think the one over here might have
been locked and not broken yeah okay
hello oh crap ah fake book fake book
what's the
do what do i do as a big book huh put
the fake book where some I put the pick
book do something with the big book
gonna hide crap there's a terrible
hiding place that was not a lot of time
in between the hidey-hole hello hi don't
ever find me yeah for fun
you'll never find me
okay all right think we're good okay so
I think we're good and that means that I
can wait here until the next episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll follow this up real quick let you
know what happens next
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
yeah just like that it's all a roof okay
all right the reason I'm eating out so
much because this game was such a part
of my childhood like it's such an
interesting person